we do know that humans are doing
something
different um from these models in part
because you know we're so power
efficient you know the human brain does
remarkable things and it does it on
about 20 watts of power and you know uh
the the AI techniques we use today use
many kilowatts of power to do equivalent
tasks so there's something interesting
about the way the human brain does this
and also we don't need as much data so
you know like self-driving cars are they
have to drive billions and billions of
miles to try and to learn how to drive
and you know your average 16-year-old uh
figures it
out with many fewer miles so there are
still some tricks I think that we have
yet to learn I don't think we've learned
the last trick I don't think it's just a
question of scaling things up um but
what's interesting is that just scaling
things up and I put just in quotes
because it's actually hard to scale
things up but just scaling things up
also appears to pay huge dividends yeah
and and it's there's some more nuanced
aspect about human beings that's
interesting if it's able to accomplish
like being truly original and novel to
you know large language models being
able to come up with some truly new
ideas uh that's one and the other one is
uh truth it's seems that large language
models are very good at
sounding like they're saying a true
thing but they don't uh require or often
have a grounding in sort of a
mathematical truth it can just basically
is a very good bullshitter so if if
there's not enough dat if there's not
enough sort of data uh in the in the
training data about a particular topic
is just going to
concoct um accurate sounding narratives
which is a very fascinating problem to
try to solve how do you get uh language
models to infer what is true or not to
sort of introspect yeah they need to be
taught to say I don't know more often
yeah and uh I know several humans who
could be taught that as well sure and
then the other stuff because you're
still a bit involved in the Amazon side
with the AI things the other open
question is what kind of products are
created from this oh so many yeah I mean
you know I just to you know we have um
Alexa and Ekko and Alexa has you know
hundreds of millions of installed base
you know inputs and so there's this
there's you know there's Alexa
everywhere and guess what Alexa is about
to get a lot smarter yeah and so that's
really you know from a product point of
view that's super exciting there's so
many opportunities there so many
opportunities shopping assistant you
know like all that stuff is amazing in
AWS you know we're building Titan which
is our foundational model we're also
building um Bedrock which our corporate
clients at
AWS our Enterprise clients they want to
be able to use these powerful models
with their own corporate data yes
without accidentally contributing their
corporate data to that model yes and so
those are the tools we're building for
them with bedrock so there's tremendous
opportunity here yeah the security the
Privacy all those things are fascinating
of how to cuz so much value can be
gained by training on private data but
you want to keep this secure that's a
it's a fascinating technical problem
this is this is a very challenging
technical problem and it's one that
we're you know making progress on and
dedicated to solving for our
customers